bonsoir à tous nous sommes le mardi 10
mai merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal comme
chaque jour nous vous expliquons votre
actualité locale avec nos invités mais
également avec les journalistes de la
rédaction tout de suite pour commencer
les titres de cette édition
le conseil d'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines a réélu son
président et ses vice-présidents hier
soir sans grand changement
une élection qui fait suite à la
décision du tribunal administratif de
versailles d'annuler une partie des
délibérations du 9 janvier suite à un
recours déposé par un collectif de
citoyens et les élus de gauche
le nouveau président de l'université de
versailles saint quentin en yvelines a
été désigné ce matin avec 22 voix contre
lors du vote et didier guillemot
enseignants chercheurs et médecins prend
la suite de jean luc hees hier à la tête
de l'ue vs qu il est notre invité ce
soir et aujourd'hui 10 mai c'est la
journée nationale de la commémoration de
l'abolition de l'esclavagé à saint
quentin en yvelines c'est cette journée
qui a été choisi pour être le point
d'orgue de la semaine pour la mémoire de
l'esclavagé avec cet après midi à
l'espace albert camus de maurepas une
exposition dédiée aux chants danses et
rythmes noirs au temps de l'esclavagé et
je vous disais en titre le conseil
d'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines a réélu son président et ses
vice-présidents hier soir une élection
qui fait suite à la décision du tribunal
administratif de versailles d'annuler
une partie des délibérations du 9
janvier dernier suite à un recours
déposé par un collectif de citoyens
ainsi que des élus de gauche le maire de
montigny le bretonneux michel auger
reprend donc son siège de président plus
de détails avec william l le g résident
des soirées sans suspense ils sont
surpris
le 9 mai dernier michel laugier est
réélu président du conseil
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
suite à l'annulation du vote du 9
janvier par le tribunal administratif de
versailles avec 43 voix sur 46 suffrages
exprimés le maire de montigny le poteau
nouveau pont son poste une partie des
délibérations du mois de janvier en des
d'annuler par le tribunal tout ça parce
que il y avait un filtrage à l'entrée
alors que nous étions dans une situation
d'état d'urgence je trouve qu'on a perdu
beaucoup de temps pour rien parce que
finalement vous voyez que on exactement
dans la même configuration de celle que
nous avions décidé au mois de janvier
donc on a perdu du temps on a perdu de
l'argent et je pense qu' il est grand
temps de se mettre au travail dans
l'intérêt des saint quentinois joséphine
coleman ce berger reprend la première
vice-présidence aucun changement pour
les onze vice-présidents
en revanche le vote s'est déroulé sans
la gauche qui a refusé d'y prendre part
en restant en retrait pendant toute la
durée de l'élection des vice-présidents
et à certains votes auxquels on n'a pas
participé tout ce qui est concerné
l'exécutif puisque de nouveaux on en est
exclue cire que l'on considère qu'il ya
des communes qui mérite d'être
représentés avec des vrais délégation
puis aller sous commune
on espérait que cette deuxième élection
allait permettre de remettre les choses
à plat c'est pas le cas on le regrette
parce que c'était un petit peu
l'occasion de repartir sur de meilleures
bases
la gauche conserve des postes de
conseillers communautaires
selon la représentation politique du
conseil d'agglomération ne serait pas
équitable
pointé du doigt par la droite lors du
conseil le coût de ces élections aux
contribuables saint quentinois et dans
l'actualité locale et nationale
aurore bergé et lui les républicains
dans l'opposition à magny les hameaux à
dénoncer le sexisme dont elle a été
victime elle a déploré sur twitter comme
vous le voyez les remarques déplacées de
ses collègues masculins après la
révélation des accusations contre denis
baupin les faits se seraient déroulés au
lendemain des accusations de harcèlement
sexuel lancées à l'encontre du député
écologiste lors du conseil
d'agglomération de lundi soir dans
lequel elle a siégé et les nombreuses
remarques sexistes qui l'ont émaillée
selon l'élu pour roberge il est
essentiel que les femmes concernées par
les que les hommes dénonce les
comportements de leur collègue aurore
bergé qui sera très prochainement
notre invité pour réagir à cette affaire
est aujourd'hui l'agencé départementale
d'insertion activity dans les yvelines
la maison de l'emploi et de la formation
de nanterre ont signé ce matin une
convention avec la sncf une signature
qui s'inscrit dans le cadre des travaux
de prolongement du rer e pour la mise en
place d'un dispositif d'insertion
professionnelle l'objectif favoriser
l'emploi durable des yvelinois en
parcours d'insertion sur les différents
marchés du programme école en
positionnant lagence activity comme
coordinateur départemental les
précisions au micro de williams elle l'a
l'objectif pour nous c'est de signer une
charte pour l'insertion des personnes en
difficulté donc cette insertion vise les
personnes qui sont des chômeurs de
longue durée les jeunes qui nous
accès l'emploi et toutes les personnes
qui ont vraiment du mal à trouver du
travail
l'objectif c'est de trouver les moyens
avec les partenaires locaux et notamment
activity d'insérer ces personnes sur le
chantier et de leur permettre d'accéder
au monde du travail avec un objectif
qualitatif de vider des cdi cdd contrat
à durée indéterminée vraiment viser de
l'emploi durable est vraiment remettre
les gens dans le monde du travail
c'est d'abord la démarche d'insertion
professionnelle qui nous intéresse
puisque ce sera les attributaires du rsa
évident mois qui seront prioritaires
pour l'accès aux 7 % d'heures réservé
sur le chantier au un processus
d'insertion c'est pour nous est
effectivement un moment important
et puis c'est un moment aussi important
parce que hall va desservir le nord des
yvelines le nom des yvelines qui est le
plus touché aujourd'hui par la crise
économique et qui est donc la partie du
département qui a le plus grand nombre
de bénéficiaires du rsa et nous recevons
ce soir en plateau le nouveau président
de l'université de versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines didier
guillemot bonsoir à vous bonsoir merci
d'avoir accepté à notre invitation où
nous avons en entretien en exclusivité
alors vous avez été élu à 22 voix sur 34
au premier tour est ce que vous vous
attendiez à cette issue je m'attendais à
une issue favorable mais comme vous
l'imaginez jusqu'au dernier moment c'est
toujours incertain et donc je suis
effectivement ravi d'abord on rallume
amitié ravi de l'issue parce que au fond
ça dit bien que ya eu des débats il ya
une campagne je trouve comme je l'aï dit
si c'est un exercice démocratique
universitaire c'est assez unique
mais au fond 22 voix sur 34
ça donne quand même un conseil
d'administration qui va pouvoir faire
vraiment des choses
alors justement vous prenez la suite de
jean luc vestiaires donc président de
l'université de versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines de 2012 à 2016
jean-luc investir qui s'est désisté
d'ailleurs lire je vous propose
d'écouter sa réaction par rapport
justement demain à sa victoire pendant
une déception il certaine amertume mais
bon ça c'est le jeu du prat il faut que
je fasse plier à 6 à ses joies et ses
peines on va dire donc
c'est rebondir de positiver bon moi j'ai
l'impression d'avoir fait le job
ce que je pouvais elle parle ce qui
attendait tout le monde manifestement il
y avait un besoin de changement que ce
soit surtout c'est que voilà qu'ils
oeuvrent au rayonnement développement de
l'université c'est ce qui m'a apporté au
mieux-être encore si possible cela
passait le moment un peu compliqué de la
communauté ont un peu déçu mais vous ça
prenne pas de chance moi je veux
vraiment saluer le travail de jean luc
baissière les quatre années on n'a pas
été facile il faut être très honnête
mais on l'a vécu je pense qu'il a fait
un travail extrêmement important il a
tenté tout fait pour que notre
université se remettent à flot
financièrement ça a été compliqué donc
vraiment sincèrement je je je veux
saluer et rendre hommage et à jean-luc
baissière et à l'ensemble de son équipe
alors si on revient rapidement sur votre
parcours on s'est compliqué car il est
assez long vous êtes enseignant
chercheur médecin vous avez travaillé
notamment sur l'infection du vih
vous coordonnez également un programme
de double diplôme de l'université paris
saclay vous êtes un homme de terrain
est-ce que cela va vous aider justement
dans votre nouvelle fonction je crois
que oui parce que ce qui m'intéresse et
vous l'avez très bien dit dans votre
parcours ce qui m'intéresse c'est ce qui
m'a toujours intéressé c'est de
construire
je suis médecin je suis aussi
épidémiologistes et puis les musiques de
terrain et dans ce parcours et bien j'ai
construit des dispositifs j'ai construit
des programmes j'ai peut être parfois de
gros programme assez lourd assez
importants sur le temps et ça je pense
que c'est vraiment
une fois la une de mes forces pour
avancer dans contexte paris sa que je
pense qu'on va y venir
alors justement voilà ma prochaine
question l'avenir c'est paris saclay
qu'elle vous êtes vous avez déjà des
décisions rapides qui vont venir par
rapport à cela alors d'abord c'est pas
des décisions c'est des réunions elles
s'imposent l'agenda est là
comme vous le savez l'iddac sein a été
évalué 7 idex a été évaluée avec une
demande de revoir les choses d'ici 18
mois
et de ce que paris saclay identifie ce
qu'on appelle l'université cible pour
utiliser un terme français je vais
travailler à ça évidemment dès demain
alors justement il ya aussi un désir
d'unifier lu vs qu de créer une
meilleure coordination avec paris saclay
qu'elle soit un peu voilà les ambitions
c'est tout ça à plat comme je l'avais
dit quand j'étais venu de notre micro il
ya quelques semaines il faut que
l'université de versailles soit force de
proposition elle l'est déjà
et il faut que institutionnellement
politiquement les supporter des projets
vers paris saclay de façon à ce que
paris saclay ce soit aussi le
département des yvelines et l'université
de versailles saint quentin en yvelines
la première chose que je vais faire
comme je lui ai annoncé que je les crée
une taxe force paris saclay en
appliquant les collègues les plus
impliqués dans la dynamique de façon à
ce qu'il y ait le coordination et nous
allons mettre au point une stratégie
alors au niveau du budget on connaît les
difficultés de l'université de saint
quentin en yvelines
est ce qu'il ya des choses à améliorer
pour justement aller vers cet avenir
paris-saclay première chose que je vais
faire aussi c'est un audit un audit
d'activité d'activité de l'ensemble de
l'université puis un audit financier
à l'issue de sa jeu
éléments un peu plus important est un
peu plus clair sur évidemment les marges
je pense que la force de paris-saclay
c'est le fait qu'il y ait une dynamique
de croissance universitaire et qu'il y
ait évidemment des financements pour des
projets dits d'excellence en fait ce
sont des projets extrêmement ambitieux
je pense que nous avons des forces dans
notre université pour y aller je pense
notamment mais pas exclusivement à tout
le champ d humanité ou sens très très
large du terme
et au fond jacques lui-même la médecine
parce que la médecine est une science de
l'humain et c'est de ce côté là qu'il a
probablement falloir mettre l'emphase
avec d'autres forces
du côté des technologies de
l'informatique voilà c'est à dire que il
falloir que notre université et
personnellement que je porte des projets
de façon à ce qu'il soit soutenu par
paris saclay alors il y avait voilà un
problème dont nous avions parlé
justement dans notre jt tous les
doctorants qui n'ont pas de contrat il
ya des emplois précaires à la fac c'est
un problème auquel vous allez vous
attacher alors il faut distinguer deux
choses il ya la question de la précarité
en rapport avec les contrats à durée
déterminée des personnels de
l'université
c'est une chose auquel je suis attaché
auquel je ferais extrêmement attention
et j'ai même annoncée dans le programme
que nous allions tenter de faire évoluer
les situations de nos personnels il ya
par ailleurs des étudiants j'ai pas
d'idée arrêtée mais les étudiants qui
sont doctorants pour moi sont des
étudiants alors certains par ailleurs
peuvent avoir des emplois peuvent avoir
des situations particulières et ça eh
bien je lui ai annoncé aussi nous allons
travailler à rédiger ou à constituer ou
à construire une charte des régimes
spéciaux étudiants et on examinera cette
question dans ce cadre là alors
justement les étudiants on va ils font
partie également de votre réussite
parce que vous avez vous avez un peu
séduire tout au long la compagnie sais
que vous avez beaucoup d'adhérents ce
justement des étudiants qu'est-ce que
vous pouvez leur dire c'est peut-être
s'ils ont peur de voir leur liberté
chandioux tête ils attendent beaucoup
justement de vous et vous et je pense
qu'ils attendent en fait d'être impliqué
dans l'université
les étudiants ont probablement beaucoup
moins de résistance au changement que
les moins étudiants ou les plus âgés
donc je fais partie ce qui ce dont ils
ont envie c'est que l'université les
emmène et les aident à participer ils
ont plein d'idées la maison des
étudiants est un bon exemple nous allons
travailler ensemble à savoir par exemple
c'est un objet il y en a d'autres
comment est ce que les étudiants peuvent
être partie prenante de l'existence et
de la vie de la maison de l'étudiant
vous voulez juste les impliquer encore
plus oui bien sûr
ils ont plein d'idées est ce qu'il ya
une volonté peut-être justement de
réhausser aussi le niveau de la faconde
dehors de partir de paris saclay de fer
que voilà ce verset de versailles saint
quentin une der heyden un petit peu plus
d'aller vers de nouveaux diplômes
peut-être des contrats de
professionnalisation alors quand on
quand on m'annonce l'idée d'aller vers
de meilleurs diplômes ça signifie que
les diplômes seraient pas si bon que ça
je pense que les diplômes notre
université sont très bons il faut les
valoriser les rendre visibles
évidemment qu'à côté de ça et le
chantier des licences de club de paris
saclay s'annonce il me semble important
d'essayer de nous spécifier de faire
exister
effectivement des formations qui peuvent
être un peu expérimentale j'ai
aujourd'hui dit que je souhaitais je
sais que c'est pas simple mais c'est
d'aller vers cette idée où les étudiants
pourraient être un peu à la carte dents
de certains de parcours
je pense que c'est très bénéficia bhl
aux étudiants c'est assez moderne ça se
fait dans beaucoup d'universités
internationale je sais pas si on
arrivera à le faire très rapidement mais
ce que je souhaite c'est que nous avions
effectivement envers des doubles
diplômes des choses qui ne se font pas
ailleurs dans le cadre de paris-saclay
sur paris sud de façon à ce que nous
ayons des spécificités une dernière
question avant de terminer l'entretien
le bac à leur approche c'est beaucoup de
nouveaux étudiants qui vont peut-être
choisir l'université
comment allez vous faire pour les
attirer justement faire université de
paris viii e de vera de versailles saint
quentin en yvelines
apb est passé où est en cours
donc là c'est un peu on est dans le
train je vais on ne va pas
changer les choses et comme pour l'année
prochaine s'est transformée en bagarre
s'est transformée d'un coup de baguette
magique
par contre pour les prochaines oui il me
semble qu'il faut avancer sur cette idée
que notre université et l est est
universités dont les particularités
c'est qu'elle est ancré sur de grands
enjeux de société
de grands enjeux de société qui sont
potentiellement visible à un niveau
international à un niveau national bien
sûr à un niveau régional
aprilia a fortiori mais je pense que
c'est dans ce sens là qu'il faut aller
vous rendez compte l'université qui
essaye de réfléchir de travail et
d'emmener ses étudiants dans les métiers
de demain qui correspondent aux grands
enjeux de la société alors je peux vous
citer comme ça quelques exemples le
spatial par exemple le climat
l'environnement par exemple le handicap
et il y en a d'autres
tout ça ce sont des enjeux de société
particulièrement important et bien
l'université de versailles développe
déjà là dedans il faut que nous mettions
en avant
merci beaucoup à didier guillemot et
maintenant nous passons un tout autre
sujet hier à l'occasion de la fête de
l'europe lycée professionnel jacques
prévert de versailles a organisé une
journée spécifique au programme une
conférence sur l'europe présentée par le
député jean-frédéric poisson et une
remise de diplômes d'euros passe retour
sur ces événements avec fanny bourdillon
le 9 mai c'est la journée de l'europe
depuis maintenant 1985
l'occasion pour le député jean-frédéric
poisson de se rendre au lycée
professionnel jacques prévert de
versailles devant une centaine de
lycéens
il y a tenu une conférence pour partager
sa vision de l'europe
la france a besoin des générations qui
viennent que rappeler à ces jeunes gens
et jeunes filles que dans quelques
années c'est eux qui auront les clés il
faudra veiller à ce que l'héritage le
plus précieux que nous avons reçus des
générations précédentes c'est-à-dire
notre civilisation et la paix
soit transmise et qu'ils aient la
volonté de transmettre cet héritage mans
l'europe un enjeu crucial pour ce lycée
qui propose des sections européennes et
on voit chaque année 10 de ses élèves
effectuent un stage en immersion de
quatre semaines en espagne
nos élèves ont déjà la possibilité de
suivre une section européenne en
espagnol et moi même j'ai la possibilité
d'enseigner même la matière
professionnelle en anglais et nous
souhaitons vraiment développer les
langues étrangères pour nos élèves afin
de faciliter encore leur recherche de
travail à la sortie du bac
après la conférence place à la remise
des diplômes europa ce certificat
atteste d'une expérience professionnelle
à l'étranger des séjours que ces lycéens
en terminale ne sont pas prêts d'oublier
on apprend à être plus responsables avec
plus autonome on est quand même un peu
livrés à nous mêmes
pendant un mois c'est vraiment quelque
chose que j'attendais depuis des années
c'était d'avoir une expérience
professionnelle en espagne et je
regrette rien je regrette pas d'être
parti depuis 2013 une quarantaine de
lycéens ont réalisé des stages à
salamanque en espagne l'année prochaine
changement de destination direction
séville et en ce mardi 10 mai jour
nationale de commémoration de
l'abolition de l'esclavagé se termine la
semaine pour la mémoire de l'esclavagé à
saint quentin en yvelines
le collectif en charge de l'événement
organisé cet après midi à l'espace
albert camus de maurepas une exposition
dédiée aux chants danses et rythmes
noirs au temps de l'esclavagé
camille lambert pour ce reportage regard
des blues broca et samba trois genres
musicaux très différents et pourtant il
possède les mêmes racines
mardi 10 mai le collectif pour la
semaine de la mémoire de l'esclavagé
saint quentin en yvelines a organisé une
exposition dédiée à la musique noire au
temps de l'esclavagé
ils ont pu recueillir avec des
instruments
de matériaux trouvés sur place et on
peut prier des styles déjà remisé qu à
partir de servir avec le mélange du
d'autre que d'inspiration d'auto musique
européenne ou amérindiens 14 panneaux
retracent l'histoire de chaque genre
musical on apprend alors que la samba au
brésil puise ses racines en afrique et
plus précisément en angola et au congo
une exposition pour rappeler
l'importance de l' esclavage sur le
monde et la musique c'est qu'un pan de
l'histoire de l'humanité déjà le premier
système mondialisé
ce que sa peau chez les trois continents
donc il faut partager quelques mois pour
pouvoir commander évolutive l'exposition
sera agrémenté année après année
d'autres courants musicaux la traite
négrière a fait plus de 25 millions de
victimes à travers le monde et c'est à
présent l'heure de notre chronique ce
soir c'est camille lambert qui nous a
rejoints en plateau pour une grande
première
bonsoir camille soir vous allez nous
présenter la première bande dessinée
avoir pour héros un chien guide
d'aveuglé écrite par georges grard
auteurs illinois alors comme vous pouvez
le constater florane je ne suis pas venu
les mains vides je vous présente donc
sparte la bd s'appelle souriez vous êtes
guidé il est sorti hier en librairie et
george grey s'est inspiré de son chien
sparte pour créer ce nouveau personnage
on écoute se présenter ce nouveau héros
seynod sa naissance jusqu'à sa retraite
avec l'ambition de montrer la sélection
de montres et d'éducation la famille
d'accueil de montrer aussi le lien qu'il
va former avec son maître cette équipe
comme il l'appelle et puis aussi bas
comme on forme cette équipe
moi ce que j'aime bien c'est apporter
vraiment le rire et la réflexion
derrière que lui rires pousse la
réflexion
c'est vrai que le chien ressemble un peu
à son propre chien lors c'est donc une
bd humoristique avec une visée
informative il s'agit d'ailleurs d'un
partenariat avec la fédération française
des associations de chiens guides
d'aveuglés alors l'idée c'est vraiment
d'expliquer aux jeunes mais aussi aux
plus grands comment se déroule le
parcours du chien guide et à quelles
problématiques sont confrontés les non
voyants
georges grard s'est donc rendu dans des
centres de formation pour recueillir le
témoignage des éducateurs des familles
d'accueil et des malvoyants 12 me
exemplaires ont déjà été vendus
essentiellement aux associations de
chiens guides et pour l'éducation
nationale
marraine de l ouvrage alors la bd fera
donc le tour des écoles auteurs n'en est
pas à son coup d'essai il a écrit une
soixantaine d'ouvragés dont une
vingtaine de bande dessinée nous
l'avions rencontré en mars lors des
journées andy fac de l'ue vs qui s'était
vous d'ailleurs calme et il avait
rencontré ont donné une séance de
dédicaces alors il était enseignant
avant de se lancer dans l'écriture il a
commencé en 2003 la bd avec les aux élus
qui traite des relations entre frères et
soeurs et depuis 2006 il a créé la banda
aide alors il met en scène pour la
première fois dans l'histoire de la bd
de jeunes héros handicapés et c'est pour
cette bd d'ailleurs qu'il avait été
invité à l'université de versailles
saint quentin
la bande à ed a obtenu le prix handi
livre du meilleur ouvrage jeunesse 2007
un thème qui lui tient particulièrement
à coeur depuis sa rencontre avec un
élève
j'ai eu un enfant handicapé dans ma
classe qui m'a dit un jour on parle de
nous les handicapés mais on nous montre
jamais et là ça a été un grand big bang
dans ma tête je me c'est vrai il n'ya
pas de héros handicapés alors je me suis
dit je vais en créer moi le message
essentiel essentiel c'est que le bien le
plus précieux c'est la vie la vie alors
quand on a des accidents de vie comme
dans le handicap mais des chagrins
d'amour des chagrins de vie aussi eh ben
il faut rebondir alors une philosophie
que l'on retrouve aussi dans son
magazine l'indispensable créé en 2014
j'ai entre les mains le dernier numéro
george grey le directeur de la
publication et plus de 50% des
contributeurs sont eux mêmes en
situation de handicap
c'est un trimestriel disponible
seulement sur abonnement est l'objectif
de ce magazine c'est de lutter contre
les préjugés parler du handicap dans la
société avec des sujets aussi variés que
le sport la culture ou encore le
tourisme et avec un humour toujours
aussi mordant
merci beaucoup camille alors peut-être
des idées de lecture pour nous
spectateurs
alors on le rappelle à sparte souriez
vous êtes grillés vous êtes guidé par
don est ressorti hier en librairie ce
qu'il y en aura d'autres
alors initialement ce ne devait être
qu'un one shot mais face au succès déjà
rencontré georges grard prévoit
peut-être de faire vivre ce partent à
nouveau dans d'autres aventures aidants
rappaz de suivre ses sorties de très
près et pour ceux qui souhaitent
rencontrer l'auteur il sera présent au
salon du livre organisé le 25 juin à la
verrière ne manquait pas sa venue chez
merci beaucoup et camille et nous
restons dans la culture hier lundi 9 mai
avait lieu la réouverture de la galerie
des carrosses du château de versailles
fermé au public depuis 2007 cette
réouverture est définitive a été rendue
possible grâce au mécénat de la
fondation d'entreprise michelin la
galerie présente l'une des plus
importantes collections de carros
d'europe
pour l'occasion toutes les voitures ont
été entièrement restauré comme vous le
montre sephora namani et patrick jacques
de dixmude
il est le joyau de la collection exposée
dans les grandes écuries du château de
versailles
il s'agit du carrosse du sacre de
charles 10,4 tonnes 5 mètres de haut
sept mètres de long
cette voiture est reconnu comme le
chef-d'oeuvre de la carrosserie
française pour l'ingéniosité de sa
mécanique la richesse de ses ors et des
ornements auquel concours tous les arts
décoratifs le carrosse dans la monarchie
française c'est le symbole du pouvoir du
pouvoir en marche et à versailles et
bien nous n'avons pas des véhicules pour
voyager nous n'avons donné que pour
montrer le roi donc il faut bien
comprendre que le carrosse c'est comme
un trône ambulants et trolls c'est à
dire aussi un objet d'art réalisées par
les meilleurs artistes et artisans de la
couronne fermé au public depuis 2007 la
galerie des carrosses vient de rouvrir
grâce au mécénat de la fondation
michelin la surface d'exposition a
doublé et s'étend à présent sur plus de
1000 mètres carrés
elle présente l'une des plus importantes
collections de carros d'europe
entièrement restauré différents films
faits à partir d'image de données de
captation 3d à l'intérieur des carrosses
permettent de comprendre l'apparition de
ces voitures est la technique utilisée
pour les fabriquer l'appareil
pédagogique est effectivement très
important pour le public parce que
finalement c'est des collections un peu
insolite
donc il faut expliquer au public d'abord
et bien pourquoi ce sont des objets
l'histoire ici chaque cas rochette une
page de l'histoire de france et puis les
faire aussi un peu rentrait bien dans
dans cette technique et pau mobile du
char funèbre de louis xviii aux voitures
de la présidence en passant par les
berlines du mariage de napoléon 1er
les carrosses de versailles ce sont des
monuments historiques et artistiques
à l'image des écuries royales bâti par
jules hardouin mansart entre 1679 et
1682 et c'est la fin de cette édition à
suivre le 7 8 sociétés présentées par
nour a dit nein objet du débat
état des lieux et réponse à la
radicalisation avec ses invités chien
c'est la fin de session je l' ai déjà
dit je vous souhaite une bonne soirée et
je vous retrouve demain pour un nouveau
journal au revoir